foreign
[Music]
at the airport the Kardashians
addressing those Bella Thorne and Scott
Disick romance rumors on keeping up all
fueled by their dripped cam this summer
it's not a good look for Scott at all
and I said are you nuts are you actually
not well maybe he was like yeah I'm
doing it to make Courtney mad I said
you're not going to make her mad for the
right reasons I think it's clear to
everyone that Scott is doing this just
to try to one-up Courtney and that seems
super malicious Courtney says that even
before taking off scott also threatened
her and rumor new boyfriend Eunice
benjima he's like you're gonna have a
great time and then he's threatening me
now he's like your little friend is
gonna get beat up every single day when
we're there
I just can't believe that he would stoop
this low and speak to her like this well
I really hope he was out of his right
mind we're just like angrily talking
thinking he's gonna scare but he would
do nothing yeah just to like just so
childish yeah Ed has chatted with Bella
several times about Scott she maintains
they were just friends we're chilling
we're friends we're cool
um I literally just saw him so yeah like
it's all chill can you clear it up once
and for all what is that relationship I
can't you you you're really getting into
it and I have absolutely nothing to say
we're friends deal with it people can be
friends it's a thing it actually it
actually happens